Hi, my name is Jesse Mostipak
and I'm a Developer
Advocate here at RStudio.
And today I want to take you on a quick
high-level tour of RStudio Cloud
from the perspective of an educator.
When you're getting ready
to teach R with RStudio,
you have two main options.
One option is to walk learners
through downloading and installing both
R and RStudio on their local machine,
after which you then have to walk
through the installation
of all the necessary packages,
as well as loading the packages.
And if you're using Git,
you've got to install git.
And more often than not
this process results
in spending a significant amount of time
troubleshooting unique installation issues
across a variety of operating systems.
Another option is to use RStudio Cloud.
RStudio Cloud is a lightweight,
cloud-based solution that allows you
to teach data science using the RStudio
IDE directly from your browser.
With RStudio Cloud
Git works out of the box
and you can avoid the majority
of the installation issues
you are likely to encounter
when you have learners
download to their personal computer.
What's more, you don't need any system
administration experience or I.T.
support to get your course
set up. Let's take a look.
Once you log into RStudio cCoud,
you have a variety of tools
available to you. In the menu on the left
we can take a look at workspaces.
You'll always have
your own personal workspace
and you can create additional workspaces
for each of your courses, like this.
To avoid having students each download
packages to their computer, we can set up
all of the projects within our workspace
using a default set of files and packages
by creating a base project.
This means we can install all of
the packages used throughout our course,
along with any files we want our learners
to have access to by default.
And we can update this base project
throughout our course as needed.
Let's check out what's available to us
within a workspace.
One of the first things we can do
is add members to our workspace
and set their default permissions either
through invitations or by using a link.
In addition to adding learners,
this is a fantastic way to get any
co-teachers and teaching assistants
added to your workspace so that
they can assist with adding learners
and setting up the workspace.
We can also create a new
RStudio Project
with a click of a button,
which will take us to an R project
that looks like what we'd see in the
desktop version of the RStudio IDE.
From here, we can share the Project
with our learners and even convert it
into an assignment.
When we create an assignment as educators
RStudio Cloud automatically
makes a copy for our learners
and flags the project with the assignment
tag from our perspective,
while showing learners either
a start or continue button
for each assignment in their workspace.
Another feature in RStudio
Cloud is the ability for educators
to look at a learner's assignment.
This means that we can run
a learner's work on RStudio Cloud
and better help them to identify
and debug any errors.
While this doesn't cover everything
you can do with RStudio Cloud,
I do hope it inspires you to check out the
possibilities at rstudio.cloud
And if you'd like to learn more,
please join us for an RStudio
Cloud webinar at one p.m.
Eastern on August 18th, 2021
right here on our YouTube channel.
We'll be showing you a prerecorded video
from one of our resident Cloud experts,
and as the video plays,
RStudio staff will be available in chat
to answer all of your questions.
I can't wait to see you there!